of this masterpiece to reveal
what could have been underneath.
Well, this happens to be the most important painting
we have in Italy by Leonardo da Vinci, and
look at the wonderful images of faces that nobody has seen
for five centuries. Look at these portraits.
They're magnificent. You see Leonardo at work.
You see the geniality of his creation, right directly
on the ground layer of the panel, and see
this cool thing, finding, I should rather say,
an elephant. (Laughter) Because of this elephant,
over 70 new images came out, never seen for centuries.
This was an epiphany. We came to understand
and to prove that the brown coating that we see today
was not done by Leonardo da Vinci, which left us
only the other drawing that for five centuries
we were not able to see, so thanks only to technology.
Well, the tablet. Well, we thought, well, if we all have
this pleasure, this privilege to see all this,
to find all these discoveries, what about for everybody else?
So we thought of an augmented reality application
using a tablet. Let me show you just simulating
what we could be doing, any of us could be doing,
in a museum environment.
So let's say that we go to a museum with a tablet, okay?
And we just aim the camera of the tablet
to the painting that we are interested to see, like this.
Okay? And I will just click on it, we pause,
and now let me turn to you so the moment the image,
or, I should say, the camera, has locked in the painting,
then the images you just saw up there in the drawing
are being loaded. And so, see.
We can, as we said, we can zoom in. Then we can scroll.
Okay? Let's go and find the elephant.
So all we need is one finger. Just wipe off
and we see the elephant. (Applause)
(Applause)
Okay? And then if we want,
we can continue the scroll to find out, for example,
on the staircase, the whole iconography is going
to be changed. There are a lot of laymen reconstructing
from the ruins of an old temple a new temple,
and there are a lot of figures showing up. See?
This is not just a curiosity, because it changes
not just the iconography as you see it, but the iconology,
the meaning of the painting,
and we believe this is a cool way, easy way,
that everybody could have access to, to become more
the protagonist of your own discovery, and not just
be so passive about it, as we are when we walk through
endless rooms of museums.
(Applause)
Another concept is the digital clinical chart, which sounds
very obvious if we were to talk about real patients,
but when we talk about works of art, unfortunately,
it's never been tapped as an idea.
Well, we believe, again, that this should be the beginning,
the very first step, to do real conservation,
and allowing us to really explore and to understand
everything related to the state of our conservation,
the technique, materials, and also if, when, and why
we should restore, or, rather, to intervene on
the environment surrounding the painting.
Well, our vision is to rediscover
the spirit of the Renaissance, create a new discipline
where engineering for cultural heritage is actually
a symbol of blending art and science together.
We definitely need a new breed of engineers
that will go out and do this kind of work and
rediscover for us these values, these cultural values
that we badly need, especially today.
And if you want to summarize in one just single word,
well, this is what we're trying to do.
We're trying to give a future to our past
in order to have a future.
As long as we live a life of curiosity and passion,
there is a bit of Leonardo in all of us. Thank you. (Applause)
(Applause)